what did you think of the new top gun
movie how accurate was it let's start
there i thought the flying was really
accurate i thought the
the type of flying they did and how they
approached the actual mission
um of course had a lot of liberties
but one thing that seems to be hard to
capture on these types of things are the
the chess game that's going on while
that type of flying is happening the
chess game between like in a dogfight
between the the pilots and the enemy or
between the different pilots i'll even
speak to just that particular mission
they flew there and for that particular
mission it's kind of a chess game with
yourself to to get everything in place
so
what kind of flight they flew is called
a high threat scenario which means they
uh have to ingress low due to uh the
surface-to-air threats that integrate
air defense systems that are nearby
and they have to ingress low and pop up
like we see in the movie
and in that particular movie that was a
pre-planned strike they knew exactly
where they're going but there's a
scenario where we have to operate in
that type of environment and we don't
know exactly where we're going to strike
or we're going to be adapting to
real-time targets and so in that
scenario you would have one of those
fighters down low like that operating as
a mission commander as a forward air
controller and he's out there calling
shots joining on those other players in
order to ensure they're pointed at the
right target so so that's a bit of the
chess game that he'll be playing
can you actually describe for people who
haven't seen the movie uh what the
mission actually is
yeah what's involved in the mission so
in this particular mission that it's
kind of what we would call a pre-planned
strike so there's a known location
that's in a heavily defended area
and the air crew in this case i believe
it was four f-18s uh on the initial
package
uh their job was to ingress very low
down a canyon to stay out of the radar
window of the surf to air threats what
does ingress mean
ingress means that they're going to be
pushing from a start location towards
the target or the objective so there's
an ingress portion of the mission and an
egress portion of the mission oh
okay uh like the entrance and the exit
correct type of thing got it but it
changes our mindset tactically quite a
bit right because when we're entering
some place we have the option to enter
but when we go drop a bomb on location
we're exiting
uh we don't have that luxury we don't
have that option so it actually changes
our tactics and our aggression level got
it and so they were flying low to the
ground and then there's a surface-to-air
missiles
that
forced them to have to fly low is that a
realistic thing it is realistic so
driving those aircraft in the clutter uh
you know
all radar systems or most i should say
are essentially line of sight and so
there can be limited by the horizon or
any clutter out there and even a number
of radars if they are located up high
and looking down towards that aircraft
the clutter all the uh the objects such
as trees and canyons
can have effect on radar systems and so
it can be a type of camouflage
so that's the camouflage for the radar
but what about
the surface air missile
is that is that a legitimate way to
avoid missiles flies so low like fly i
guess below
their uh
their level
as far as i know you know you can fly
under any radar right now
we don't have necessarily radars that
can look through anything so there is
always going to be the ability to mask
yourself
but with a larger number of assets and
distributed communication networks where
those radars are looking makes all the
difference and i said they are
ingressing pass and i ads and that's an
integrated air defense system and that
linking of uh air defense systems is
what makes it um so hard so complicated
is that the sensors and the weapons are
disassociated from each other so that if
you took out the target that was
shooting at you it still has the ability
to um to intercept you from another
radar location
so it's distributed and it's stronger
that way
you mean the the surface-to-air missiles
if you like it's a
it's a distributed system in that if you
take out one
they're still able to
sort of integrate information about your
location and strike at you correct and
there's a lot of complication that can
go you know once we start thinking about
distributed systems like that and the
ability to self-heal and repair and
adapt to um
losses it's an interesting area are you
responsible for thinking about that when
you're flying an airplane to some degree
um when we ingress to an area like that
we're presented with um information
about targets air to air or air surface
or surface air i should say
and we can essentially see where
essentially the danger zone if you will
uh is located uh and so essentially we
would stay out of that and so having a
full picture of um
the environment is extremely important
because you know at the end of the day
if we go in that circle we can die
pretty quickly so it's absolutely
crucial so there's regions that have
higher and lower danger
based on your understanding of the
actual whatever the the the the surface
the air missile systems are so you can
kind of know
that's interesting i wonder how
automated that could be too especially
when you don't know
it seems like in the movie they knew the
location of everything
i imagine that's less known in most
cases
and also
a lot of those systems might be a little
bit more
ghetto if i can use that technical term
like um i've gotten uh ad hoc maybe is
the uh
i don't know but you know having uh just
recently visited ukraine and seeing a
lot of aspects of the way that war is
fought
there's a lot of improvised type of
systems so you take height
high tech like advanced technology but
the way you deploy it and the way you
organize it is very
improvised and ad hoc and is responding
to the uncertainty in the dynamic
environment and so
from an enemy perspective or whoever is
trying to deal with that kind of system
it's hard to figure it out because uh
it's like me
i played tennis for a long time and it's
always easier to play this is true for
all sports uh play tennis against a good
tennis player versus a crappy tennis
player
because the crappy tennis player is full
of uncertainty
uh and that's really difficult to deal
with it seemed like in the movie the
systems were really well organized
uh and so you could plan and there was a
very nice ravine that went right down
the middle of them that's how movies
work isn't it yeah but no i absolutely
agree so you know um what you say is a
is a very good point and as you know if
we were to take a
a chunk of airspace and break it up into
little bits you know there'd be places
that are better to fly or less less good
to fly
um and
you know we are seeing that now with
what they call manned unmanned teaming
uh we see tactical aircraft or you know
some type of aircraft or platform that's
being uh automated and it's not being on
made in traditional sense uh where
people think aircrew are flying around
to conduct missions but it's very high
level uh objective orientated
mission planning that allows the air
crew to act more as a mission planner
mission commander versus having to just
pick the right assets or fly them around
and or manipulate them
somewhat physically
so actually going back to the chest
thing can you elaborate on what you mean
playing a game of chess with yourself
what's when you're flying that mission
what exactly do you mean by that well
there's a few people you're usually
fighting against in the air you know
there's the bad guys and then there's uh
physics and and mother nature right so
um
when we're down at about a hundred feet
um it's a chess game to stay alive for
the pilot and it's a chess game for the
wizzo to
process the information he needs and
then communicate it to all those other
aircraft that were flying around to
ensure that they're putting their
weapons on the right target what's the
wizzo wizzo is a weapons systems officer
he's a backseater who is not a pilot but
they're responsible for radar
manipulation and communications and uh
weapons appointments of certain natures
so the the chess game is against physics
against the enemy uh
time
time what about your own
psychology fear
uncertainty no
no there's no time for that type of
self-reflection while we're flying um
i want to get i want to get to that but
i i don't want to forget the point that
you made about increased randomness
being a tactical advantage you know as
as we
as you mentioned you know you can
introduce autonomy in there and when you
when you bring autonomy in there and my
expectation would be as we bring
different uh abilities and machine
learning as we gather more data
we're going to be able to bring the the
tactical environment around that jet the
war space that it goes into will almost
be at a stochastic level from the
enemy's perspective where it'll almost
seem like
every tactical environment they go in
will be random and yet very deadly
because
the system is providing a new tactical
solution essentially for that particular
scenario instead of just training to
particular tactics that have to be
repeatable and trainable and lethal
right but not necessarily the most
lethal because they have to be trainable
uh but if we can introduce ai into that
into and to have a level of randomness
or at least appearance of randomness due
to the complexity
you know i would say like a stochastic
uh tactical advantage because even our
own blue fighters won't be able to
engage in that fight because it would it
would be unsafe essentially for anything
else uh and i think that's where we have
to drive to because otherwise it's
always this chicken and mouse cat game
about whose tactics and who knows what
but if knowledge is no longer a factor
um it's gonna make things a lot
different that's really interesting so
out of the many things
that are part of your expertise your
your journey you're also working on
autonomous and semi-autonomous systems
the use of ai and machine learning and
uh man-to-man teaming all that kind of
stuff we'll talk about it
uh but you're saying
sort of when people think about the use
of ai in war in military systems they
think about like
computer vision for perception or
processing of sensor information in
order to extract from it actionable
knowledge kind of thing but you're
saying you could also use it to generate
randomness that's difficult
to work with in a like a game theoretic
way like it's difficult to respo for
human operators to respond to exactly
that's really interesting okay so
back back to tom cruise and top gun
what about the dog fighting uh what
aspects of that were accurate so
dogfighting is kind of uh an interesting
um conversation because it's not the
most tactically relevant skill set
nowadays uh by traditional standards
because the the ranges with which we
engage and employ weapons are very
uh significant and so if we're in a
scenario or in a dog fight like that
a lot of things have probably gone wrong
right and that's kind of how this
mission was set up right it was a you
know a no-win type scenario most likely
um and so for a dogfight the aircraft
size and the ranges and the turn
radiuses make it so it's not very
theatrical right the aircraft looks
small and while it's intense with the
systems i have and the sensors and what
i'm feeling and all that
if i you know we've done it and we've
done it right we take video of that and
it's just like a blue sky and you see a
little dot out there so not very
interesting and so
anytime it really looks interesting in
dogfight arena um that's most likely uh
fiction because we really only get close
for you know a millisecond as we're
zipping past each other at the merge
you're breaking my heart right i know
breaking my heart
no i i know
you can go and have fun but you know in
a dogfight specifically maybe that was
more common in the earlier wars of world
war ii and before that where the is is
it due to the
sort of the range and the effectiveness
of the weapon systems involved
exactly and the accuracy of the
targeting systems that range but there's
also a train of thought um that hasn't
actually been tested out yet which is
with the advent of
advanced electronic warfare ew
and or
unmanned assets the battle space may get
so complex and missiles uh may
essentially just get
uh dropped out of the sky or wasted such
that you're going to be enclosed with
either ir missiles or guns
if it's a no kidding
you know must defend type scenario first
of all what's electronic warfare you
know it's basically trying to get
control of electromagnetic spectrum um
for the interest of um whatever
operation is going on so in the tactical
environment a lot of that is trying to
deceive the radar or can we deceive the
missile or just you know stop their
guidance things of that nature
man it's a battle in the space of
information of digital information
yeah well f22 and f35 right f22 is a big
expensive aircraft and it was made to be
a great fighter
but the f-35 is not as great of a
fighter but it's it's an electronic
warfare and mission commander platform
of the future uh where information is
what's going to win the war instead of
the best dog fighter and so it's
interesting dichotomy there what's the
best airplane ever made fighter jet ever
made i know the aviators in the in the
audience are going to
hate my answer because they're going to
want that sexy you know muscly f-14
tomcat type fighter or or maybe p-51
type aircraft but
the
f-35 is maybe not the best dog fighter
but it doesn't have to get in a dog
fight right it's like how you be the
best knife fighters not getting a knife
fight sometimes lockheed martin f-35
lightning ii
looks pretty sexy there's two real
strengths you can have as a fighter you
can you can have the ability to kind of
out-muscle your fighter uh your your
opponent and beat him on g's and power
and rate around on them and then there's
the other side of that which is uh you
can be overly maneuverable uh you can
bleed energy quickly and that's what the
f3 f18 was good at because it had to be
heavier to land on aircraft carry we had
to give it extra bulk
but it also needed special mechanisms to
slow down enough to land on aircraft
carriers so it made it very maneuverable
and what that leads to a lot of times
the ability to get maybe the first shot
in a fight
which is very good but if you do make
that sharp turn you're going to bleed a
lot of your energy away and be more
susceptible for follow-on shots if that
one's less susceptible and so there's
this kind of aggression non-aggression
game you can play depending on the type
of aircraft you're fighting where does
the f-35 land on that spectrum the f-35
lands somewhere behind the f-22s so
there'll probably be a row of f-22s or
f-18s and f-35 will be out back but
it'll be enabling a lot of the warfare
that's happening in front is it one of
the more expensive planes
because of all the stuff on it it
certainly is yeah
in the movie they have tom cruise flied
over mach 10. so maybe
can you say
what are the different speeds
accelerations feel like mach 1 2 3
or hypersonic have you ever flown
hypersonic no
um does it get how tough does it get
i'm just going to call out the the bs of
ejecting at mach 10 just for the record
because in the movie uh there's been i
think at least one ejection that was
supersonic uh and i'll just say you know
it was not pretty but he survived um so
there would have to be some interesting
mechanisms to eject successfully at mach
10 but i'll digress on that for the
moment yeah that seemed very strange he
just walked away from it but anyway so
you know he seemed disheveled
okay it's tom cruise you know it's it's
like uh chuck norris or something
indestructible yeah so it doesn't age
yeah
uh but anyway so what
um
what's interesting to say about the
experience of ma of the as you go up
does it get more and more difficult
in the end of the day crossing the sound
bear is much like crossing the speed
limit on the highway you don't really
notice anything
um when to cross that at least in f-18
because we have a lot more weight than
most fighters is typically we'll do that
in a descent
and we'll do that a full afterburner uh
just dumping gas into the engine
and so that'll get us over the fastest i
think i've got about 1.28
but what's interesting people realize is
that if i take that throttle and i'm an
afterburner and i just bring it back and
just bring it back to mill which is full
power just not afterburner
the de-acceleration is so strong due to
the air friction that it throw you
forward your straps almost you know i
would say you know maybe like seventy
percent as strong almost as has trapping
on the boat it's pretty strong
um so it's almost like a reverse car
crash just for the acceleration so the
acceleration you know is usually kind of
slow and you don't feel anything of
course when you're crossing through it
but the acceleration is pretty violent
the deceleration is violent huh okay
uh but is there
is there a fundamental difference
between like mach 1 and hypersonic mach
5 and so on does it require like super
special training
and is that something that's
used often in warfare is that not really
that no so hypersonic human flight in if
it exists is not something that's
employed tactically
in um in any sense right now that i'm
aware of so
um you know i think of hypersonic
technology i think of uh missiles and
weapon systems and delivery platform i
don't think of fighter aircraft
necessarily i can think of bomber or
reconnaissance aircraft perhaps but
those would be more efficient very long
long range i imagine acceleration would
be kind of gentle honestly
the thing you experience is the
acceleration not the actual speed
there's been just a small tangent a lot
of discussion about hypersonic nuclear
weapons like missiles from you know
russia
uh bragging about that is this something
that's a significant concern or is it
just a way to flex about different kinds
of weapon systems
hypersonics i do think pose uh a
challenge for our detection systems
because there are
um
you know there are design considerations
in these sensor systems as always right
and when you build them and the
technology progresses to a point where
maybe it's not feasible to use that
technology you know there's a problem
but with the
you know the all domain and kind of
cross domain data linking capabilities
we have um
it's less of you know
it's more of an integrated picture i'll
say um and so the hypersonics um
are really
what it is is uh how fast can we detect
and destroy problems you're just
shortening the time available to do that
we call something like that the kill
chain right it's it's from um locating a
target and identifying it and
you know essentially authorizing its
destruction by whatever means uh
employing and then actually following up
to ensure that you did what you said you
were going to do in some sense right
does it need another re-attack something
of that nature and so
there's an old dog fighting framework
you could call it it's called the ooda
loop that kind of made its way in the
engineering business now but the old
observe orientated side act was
initially a a fighter mechanism in order
to get inside that kill chain of your
opponent and break it up so that he
can't
uh process his kill chain on you and so
hypersonic's a way of shortening those
those windows of opportunity to to
react to that
i wanted to what do like how much do you
have to shorten it in order for
the defense systems not to work anymore
it seems like uh
it's very you know i
i'm both often horrified by the thought
of nuclear war
but at the same time
wonder
what that looks like
when i dream of extreme competence in
defense systems i imagine that not a
single nuclear weapon can reach the
united states by missile
with the defense system
defense systems but then again i also
understand that these are extremely
complicated systems the amount of
integration required and because you're
not using them
i mean this is exactly
there could be you know there's like an
intern somewhere
that like forgot to update the code the
fortran code that like is going to be
make the difference because you don't
have the opportunity to really
thoroughly test
um which is is really scary of course
the systems are probably incredible
if they could be tested but because they
can't be really thoroughly tested in
actual
um
in an actual attack i wonder
i mean i guess one assumption there
would be that
these hypersonic missiles would only be
launched and the case would attack
um it'd be interesting if there were
other hypersonic objects that we could
use to flex those systems another thing
that actually happened i just have a
million questions i want to ask you it's
fascinating to me
uh is there's a bird strike on the plane
does that happen often yeah it's a
series they damaged the the engine and
they made it seem like it's a serious
exactly a serious issue i've hit birds
um i've i know someone that took a
turkey vulture to the face
through the cockpit right shattered the
cockpit knocked him out
um i think that
it actually i don't know him personally
about the story i know from uh the
command i was at and uh i believe the
backseater had to punch out
and punch them both out because he was
unconscious you know in the front seat
from the bird
um it can kill you from hitting you it's
you know it's like a bowling ball going
250 miles an hour
um
it can take out an engine uh
very easily uh
every airport i've flown at in the navy
i've had to check the the bird condition
if you will to see how many birds i've
we've had to cancel flights because of
because there's too many of them around
the airport some airports even have bird
radars no teleport there are systems
that monitor the bird condition there is
yeah there's actual radar systems and
you can go in the um certain bases you
have to call up and they'll tell you
what it is for the day or for that hour
and other ones have it in like their
their weather report that goes out with
the radio
what are some technological solutions to
this or is this just
uh
because it's a low probability event
there's no real solution for it i would
say it's not a low probability event i
mean this is happening a lot i mean
although the hits themselves aren't
necessarily that common or i'll say a
catastrophic hit either a near miss or a
hit or the pilot having to actively
maneuver to avoid it is pretty common
and in fact it seems stressful it is
it's so common in fact that we know that
you never want to try to go over or you
never want to go under a bird if you see
it in front of you you always want to
try to go over it because what they'll
do immediately if they see you is and
you startle vegetables they'll bring
their wings in and just drop straight
down to try to get out of the path it's
interesting i didn't know they did that
but so if you immediately if you try to
go under them they're gonna be dropping
into you so you typically want to try to
go above them is this something you can
train for or no um
is this one of those things you have to
really experience it's a skill set that
um you somewhat train for
in the duties of being a fighter pilot
in a sense right being able to react to
your environment very quickly and make
make decisions quickly so is that one of
the more absurd things
challenges you have to deal with in
flying is there other things sort of
maybe weather conditions
like harsh weather conditions is there
something that would maybe don't often
think about in terms of
the challenges of flying birds in a way
aren't a ridiculous threat for us it's
it's
a safety threat that
you know anything physical in the air is
something that we really have to be
careful about whether we're flying
formation off of the aircraft right next
to us or whether
uh it's a turkey vulture at 2 000 feet
or a flock of 5 000 birds like at the
runway we have to wave off you know and
although they're low probability a lot
of bases will have like actual
environmental protection agency
employees that are responsible for
safely removing migratory birds or
different animals
that may be in the runways or flying
about
wow i didn't know what a turkey vulture
is and it really does look like a mix
between a vulture and a turkey
and
look kind of dumb no offense to turkey
vultures um
in that movie who was the enemy nation
was it uh i mean i think i guess they
were implying it's iran
or or is it russia i didn't think they
were implying any particular nation
state frankly i think they did a
somewhat decent job of having some
ambiguous fifth generation fighters
um
the location and and the stockpile like
i get like how the story kind of
insinuates certain things but they seem
to a good job of not having anything
directly pointing to another nation
which i thought was you know the good
move i i enjoy these type of movies as
an aviator and
you know as an american right because
it's a feel-good movie but um you know
we shouldn't be celebrating going to war
with any particular country you know
china russia whoever may have these
weapons it's it's fun to watch but it
would be an incredibly serious event to
be employing these weapons
you